when I shop for clothes I don't really
look at it as a men's section and a
women's section I just shop the entire
store I just look for the things that
look cool on me and fall on me I think
in the modeling world the reason why
they choose some androgynous looking men
is because it makes it more high-fashion
more editorial androgynous guy it's more
striking and draws more attention from
all types of pies when I saw Ruby Rose
like I was like you're a pretty woman
but like if you were a guy you put on a
leather jacket with the tattoos and
everything
I definitely think that's very sexy I
identify as a woman but I also totally
accept and love my masculine traits as
much as I love my feminine traits
drogyny is definitely spicing things up
I've just always been obsessed with
David Bowie he's always done that
perfectly seamless feminine to masculine
masculine to feminine and he didn't care
what anyone thought about it it was just
so perfect and amazing every time he did
it as long as my hair is down and I'm
dressed with clothing I like it just
feel good it's kind of beautiful that we
can all just be ourselves now and we can
still have jobs where you don't look
like everyone else someone's so
unapologetically themselves I think that
is the most attractive thing in a person